I'm looking for my connection we were
rerouted through
um wherever it is we are
[Music]
hello Wilhelmina hello William
how have you been over the last 20 years
25 maybe I've been 49 forever and ever
now lucky you I feel like I've been in
my 50s since my 20s that's so true true
you don't have to agree with me
attention Boston and Austin passengers
those slots have been delayed until
further notice those two flights just us
yes unbelievable
they're saying this could be bad A Storm
of the Century what are you worried
about everything I was diagnosed with
anticipatory anxiety is that a real
thing oh yeah right now I'm worried that
we're lost look around we are looking
around look around walking around relax
you're already living out your worst
case scenario love being stuck here with
you yeah you're making a good point
what are you looking for in there photos
of the kids the family I know how bad
they wanted that just wasn't in the
cards was that your daughter yeah it
really wasn't what you said that we
wanted different things you you left you
let go this Behavior this is exactly why
we broke up so basically my personality
okay yes this is not at all how I
imagine our reunion will you imagine
this
when people break up there's the thing
that they tell each other and then
there's the truth that you never told me
I was in love with you and I couldn't
turn that on and off like a switch and
a brain drops flush rainbows have you
ever wondered what if someone you know
this facility will power down to
essential function only come on is that
a thing oh it's a thing
[Music]
I have a good life but I never again let
anybody that made me feel the way you do
[Applause]
[Music]
if we could see our memories in advance
would we do anything different
just for you